dernière volet victorieuse
fêtée par le public célébré par ses
rivaux Roger Federer 41 ans vient de
mettre un point final à sa carrière
exceptionnelle
c'était une aventure incroyable
voici les adieux émus d'un géant du
sport mondial
Rafael Nadal rival historique mais
partenaires hier soir cette nuit aussi à
l'émotion hier soir très entouré il a
quitté le cours la main sur le cœur dans
les bras des siens et ceux de la famille
du tennis
mais moi j'ai envie de chialer ça me
rappelle comme quand Roger patoulacci il
avait arrêté la pétanque
je te jure comme une madeleine comme une
madeleine j'ai chialise je me rappelle
non il a d'ailleurs lancé sa dernière
boule ouais et après terminé j'avais
chialé je te jure non mais c'est
incroyable je suis fou de dire j'ai
rencontré un jour avant et bien sûr je
vous ai pas raconté une histoire vraie
histoire vraie la classe absolue je suis
dans un restaurant japonais anawa juste
à côté de RTL mais il y avait plus RTL à
l'époque parce que c'était je dirais
rencontré récemment et je suis en train
de manger là-bas je vous jure que c'est
vrai vrai histoire je passe et il est
avec plein de choses autour de la table
et il y a un des gars à la table qui me
demande une photo se lève ce que je
prends une photo avec toi moi je sais
pas j'ai posé faire une photo avec j'ai
posé lui demander je vais partir et là
je dis non mais attends oui mais je dis
je veux bien faire une photo est trop
dur et la Roger s'est levé et a dit
attendez on fait une photo tous les
trois j'ai fait une photo avec Roger le
gars et moi et après j'ai fait une photo
avec Roger après réduire est venu dormir
à la maison
sachez même que le lendemain matin Roger
est reparti avec mon V8
voilà non mais c'est vrai c'est pas une
balle non non mais c'est vrai que j'ai
vu un amour très très sympathique voilà
et aussi j'ai déjà rencontré dans les
vestiaires de Roland-Garros mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans un match
non mais je veux dire que c'est vrai je
prépare une exhibition et je me retrouve
dans les vestiaires de Roland-Garros
j'avais attention ils m'ont fait un truc
de fou j'avais même mon vestiaire et
tout non
il y a Rafa qui arrive et là c'est
vous avez échangé là on parle un peu
téiste tu vois ouais on fait attention
on va faire choper etc
je suis un petit peu dans le métier
j'ai fait une photo avec lui on sait qui
on sait qui fait il est venu dormir à la
maison aussi et il a pris le la Smart
[Applaudissements]
box
Djokovic c'est un pote j'avais loué une
maison et il avait été propriétaire de
la maison à côté
on a fait quoi on a un ping-pong avec
lui et puis même on s'entraînait ils
s'entraînait dans le sud et un jour et
il est très sympa du comique un jour je
joue au tennis et il voit que c'est moi
il rentre sur le coup il rentre sur mon
cours et donc moi je fais on est là on a
réservé
ça va on a réservé là-haut jusqu'à 19h
et là il arrive il fait une réunion avec
moi il pousse le gars il va dit vas-y on
fait un petit match en trois points
de la main gauche
[Applaudissements]
j'ai joué il jouait de la main gauche et
à ce soir j'ai pas envie d'en parler
j'ai fait énormément de Paris
et bien sûr j'embrasse mon frérot Stan
qui a fait un très beau résultat mais
c'est là que lui il va vous confort on
stagne qui revient très fort mon stand
Wawrinka et qui lui pour le coup
vraiment dort à la maison même là je
crois qu'il est en train de dormir
t-shirts après j'ai l'impression
exactement